what I'll be presenting on today is work
that I came into that was already
ongoing
Linda Nicolai who was one of my mentors
during my postdoc along with Robert
heimer
both of them are co-investigators kopi
eyes on a study of injection drug users
gay men and their sexual partners in st.
Petersburg Russia and I have to say
Russia because people always think I'd
mean Florida otherwise so I did not
design the study I can't take credit for
its create creativity for its insight
I'm analyzing the data so I'm here to
present really mostly their work so the
first thing you see about this slide
probably is that it's about Russia and
we don't hear a lot about HIV in Russia
so what the heck were we doing there st.
Petersburg is a lovely place I'll give
you the the little Lonely Planet version
of it and just a couple seconds it was
built it was commissioned pretty much in
the early 18th century by Peter the
Great it's called the Venice of the
Baltic because it's built on 42 little
islands and islets separated by canals
and you can take cool like vaporetto
through it and it's incredibly beautiful
and it's like done in this totally
baroque style and it's pretty it's a
trippy place it's where the Hermitage is
so why are we in Russia why do we go all
the way there to study HIV we have
plenty of HIV in North America there's a
lot of HIV in the developing world
that we know of but this might seem like
kind of an esoteric place to be doing it
but you know and I'm an epidemiologist I
want to go where the diseases that's why
I work with sexually transmitted
infections among homosexually active men
because we're number one with a bullet
with HIV in this country we're the ones
who get HIV more than anyone else that's
true in a lot of countries so what's the
interest in Russia
epidemiologists you know you're all in
the public health program so you know
what this is you know the the water pump
outside the John snow pub in London it's
like we got water pumps here you know
what are we going all the way to Russia
to find a problematic water pump for
well I'll give you a little background
on Russia and it'll lead up to why we're
doing an HIV study there Russia has been
can you hear me okay okay Russia's been
through a lot in the 20th century unless
he just beamed down from Mars you know
that started in the early 20th century
as Czarist state which had only recently
gotten rid of serfdom it was futile ISM
that most of the citizens were not
citizens they were actually slaves and
their vassals and then went through a
revolution world war war on a Revolution
World War two which killed 30 million
Russians this is a memorial a plaque a
carved relief by one of the two places
in the neva river which went frozen
during the two winters that it was
blockaded by by the Nazi army that there
was you know one of two places in the
city where you could get water with your
bucket and then run home hoping that a
sniper didn't pick you off while you got
home so these are kind of tough people
they've been through a lot what brought
us to HIV is things that have happened
in the more recent past in 1989 through
91 really was the period of transition
from Marxism to to a capitalist economy
and a huge number of a great deal of
turmoil happened with that it's as you
know for the Americans in the audience
we're we're used to a very stable form
of government here imagine that changed
within a short period of time that was a
difficult transition period but what was
even a bigger deal was the economic
collapse that came in 1994 as my
colleagues in st. Petersburg as one as
old 11s said to me we thought it was
hard to get bread and milk in the
grocery stores under communism but then
after the economic collapse that it was
just ridiculous old a people the elderly
people just stopped receiving pension
paychecks were no longer being cut even
though people were showing up to the
factory for work every day and every
week the system the the infrastructure
of the country basically fell apart it's
one of the bizarre cases that we know of
where life expectancy for a country
actually went down during the early
1980s that's pretty much unprecedented
except in some some places in
sub-saharan Africa due to HIV this was
primarily due to other factors striking
rise in Russian mortality is beyond the
peacetime experience and industrialized
countries with a five-year decline in
life inspectin see in over four years
time many factors operate simultaneously
including economic and social
instability high rates of tobacco and
alcohol consumption poor nutrition
depression and deterioration of the
healthcare system that appeared in JAMA
about 12 years ago I would throw in
there too the interpersonal violence and
suicide also took a number of lives
particularly those of men during the
post-soviet period so okay what's that
got to do with HIV well in any it's
almost like in a war more people die of
infectious diseases following a war
during award then usually die from
bullets or shrapnel with turmoil comes
ill health effects and this is kind of a
case study in that this appeared by he's
got a he's got an Armenian name but he's
a Russian writer in the in Journal of
STD and AIDS and I think it sounds a
little bit like a moral panic what he's
getting to here but it also frames the
issue I think fundamental cultural and
social and economic transitions happened
during this period sustained economic
crises worse than the quality of life we
have poverty refugee obelisk refugee
migration and fatalism concerning the
future
and we had social acceptance of
prostitution which has it's been a pro
and cons temporary sexual relationships
among young people in declining age at
first sex and whether or not you think
these are you know morally or ethically
shiny and good for you they they can
have deleterious health effects so the
big thing that happened that concerns
HIV during this period of turmoil was
remember you had a lot of out-of-work
people you had a lot of people who were
not receiving government stipends that
they were used to including a huge
number of veterans of the Afghan war
many of whom were disabled and didn't
really have a way of surviving who took
advantage of existing drug trade routes
coming in from not the Golden Triangle
of Southeast Asia but the Golden
Triangle of Southwest Asia following the
Afghan war and following the turmoil
that happened with the Soviet excursion
into Afghanistan in 1980 and it's
aftermath yet a lot of poppies grown
there kind of like we saw with the
Taliban not so long ago and black tar
which is heroin which is some one of the
stuff that comes from Mexico it's very
bare minimally processed called Jordan
II which means black it's essentially
opium it's gunk was getting dragged into
Russian cities very very cheaply and
what happened is a huge proportion of a
birth cohort became addicted to heroin
we know that in the United States the
number one birth cohort year for picking
heroin was 1955 and although it hasn't
been formally quantified all the
anecdotal evidence suggests that the
years that people most picked up heroin
the birth years were 1978 to 1982 so
you've got this bolus of folks who
picked up heroin moving through the
demographic Python as time goes by and
they've acquire and transmitted
HIV don't say I'm just going to the next
slide so before we did this study what
led us to do it a study of HIV among
injection drug users in st. Petersburg
well we had some evidence that there was
a problem there were you know studies of
varying validity and generalizability
that were showing two to four percent of
the ideas in the city we're infected in
98 then 11 to 18 percent by 2030 percent
by 2002 looks like we've got an emerging
infection problem here what we now know
independent of this study of the study
I'll be presenting here but that that
contributes to it Russia now is one of
the fastest-growing epidemics in the
world about 1 percent of the Russian
population is HIV infected that
translates to half a million to 1.5
million Russians given the appropriate
confidence intervals around everything
but unlike many other countries unlike
other industrialized countries the vast
majority of the infections are among
injection drug users we also saw some
other indicators that injection drug
users were not the only population being
affected positive test prevalence which
HIV testing is done for almost all women
who present at a hospital to give birth
if they haven't had if they're getting
prenatal care it's done then if they
haven't had prenatal care they do a
rapid test to the staff they gather the
the heart that will prove that neonatal
transmission it went the prevalent
positive test prevalence went from
nothing in 1998 in the city to almost
one and a half percent by 2002 not huge
numbers well actually that's that's
that's a pretty high positive test
prevalence for pregnant women in the
developed world the good thing is most
you know nearly all of these women do
get heart but we are nevirapine rather
but the rapid rise was what concerned us
another population that they did 37
percent of st. Petersburg street youth
were found to be
hiv-infected the problem was you know
it's directly it's clear that the that
it's going to be higher among those who
inject but then it was also higher among
those using inhalants and you don't get
HIV from inhalants it was independently
associated with being an orphan and
being a double orphan more than a single
orphan and those aren't things that
transmit HIV so clearly social
disruption was playing a part in this
and then what led directly to this study
was um they noticed that between 2001
and 2003 the proportion the proportion
of newly diagnosed cases newly reported
cases went from 5 to 20% which mean
which was a positive possible indicator
that HIV was no longer just being
transmitted within the core group of
injection drug users but then spreading
on to their sex partners spilling over
to the other people at risk and the
question was will enough of this happen
to sustain a generalized heterosexual
epidemic like his seen in other areas of
the world so this is the group that got
together to talk about those questions
there were four sites in the US
including us partnering with the
biomedical Center in st. Petersburg the
sexual acquisition and transmission of
HIV cooperative agreement program to
look at the role of sexual transmission
within cores meaning gay men and drug
users they included the non injection
drug users because of so much sexual
transmission going on between crack
cocaine users and to look at what the
you know what the overall epidemic
effect would be to people outside those
groups oh I was I'm not a sorry didn't
switch this slide around this is part of
the background of why we did the study
because the study included gay men I
gave you background on I'd use on other
populations in st. Petersburg now a
little late I'll give you the
information that we had about gay men in
Russia prior to doing this study which
was basically Jack
pretty much everything I mean you know
you go to the latest information on the
Euro surveillance website your survey
once dot euro or something you know the
latest thing they've got for Russia is
one small study four hundred guys a
total convenient sample of guys showing
up at gay bars they didn't even wait for
how long you know wait them by how often
they went to bars so it's really just a
study of how many people started stat
we're spending around a bar at any given
moment it's not the most method
logically strong survey but it found
one-and-a-half percent had reported an
hiv-positive test this is all we this
was pretty much all we knew about gay
men and HIV in Russia to that point but
37 percent had not used a condom for
their last act of anal sex a huge
proportion of sex trade but one in five
had either paid for sex or been paid for
sex 37 percent also had female partners
so there's a lot of potential not a lot
of HIV but a lot of potential for
transmission within the population and
then outside the population so that made
us want to study gay men in Russia too
the methods that south cap used it was
pretty much a cross-sectional study
between 2005 and 2008 they sampled from
the two core groups and also their male
and female sexual partners so we had two
core respondent driven sampling
respondent driven sampling it begins
with seed participants like let's say
you're gonna be in a study of public
health students and you get into the
study the traditional way like by maybe
answering an ad what happens then is
you're asked to recruit other members of
your population because you know those
people and because you got paid 20 bucks
to be in the study they'll pay the other
person you recruit 20 bucks but then
they'll give you five because you act
you've successfully recruited somebody
else it's not so much to twist your arm
to twist other people's arms
it's enough to say thanks and make you
not feel taken advantage of if you
actually do it it differs from a snow
bowl sample and that he'd at each step
with each recruitment you weight by the
inclusion probabilities so you say if
eight of the ten other public health
students that you know are female but
the one person you recruited was male
that's kind of not random recruitment so
you can do through the through the magic
of mathematical weighting allegedly with
long enough recruitment chains you can
get your sample to emulate a probability
sample but you're right it doesn't
really happen in real life it's a lot
better in theory it turns out that our
diya
seems to be about a recruitment tool
than a sampling tool it's somewhere
between just a crude snow ball sample
and an actual probability sample and
that's why we're hosting a small
symposium in the spring called RDS 2.0
to see what we can do with with
technique blood specimens to test for
HIV were tested but we're we're at
Eliza's and Western blots to confirm the
positives I don't know unless slide we
also tested for syphilis cert we did
syphilis serologies tested for gonorrhea
chlamydia and Hep C and B we used
anonymous structured questionnaires
using Cassie which is basically that you
take your a questionnaire on a laptop
instead of paper and pencil and we asked
for information on sexual risk behaviors
and then information about up to five
most recent sexual partners and got the
information about social networks that I
described earlier that he needed to do
the waiting and here's what we got we
got 669 ID use 231 homosexually active
men and those don't overlap because the
guys who did overlap those two groups
were 22 all of 22 so we don't have a lot
of power to look
almost sexually active men here but we
have more and we have a better probably
a better sample of data than in previous
studies the HIV the prevalence of HIV
antibody among the injection drug users
is huge
it's 44% that's a lot that was higher
that you know that's that even even it's
a follow up to 30 that's that's a huge
number of people among homosexually
active men who didn't inject drugs it
was 7% which is not which is definitely
present it's about half what you would
see in a city its size in the United
States or our about three-quarters what
you would see in Europe the interesting
thing is the gay men who injected drugs
looked a lot more like they get look
like the drug injectors who weren't gay
men then they gay men they didn't inject
so their risk is you know possibly
coming from injection rather than from
sex we don't know yet
hepatitis C nearly universal nearly
ubiquitous among the people who injected
and a heavy burden of STI is among
anybody I mean you screen any group of
people and you get prevalence for
bacterial sexually transmitted
infections of six eight and fourteen
percent that's a lot of people with
chlamydia gonorrhea on board the
proportion of the people who were
positive who were previously diagnosed
is pretty low in this country what
proportion of people with HIV don't know
that they have HIV do you know yeah
that's about 20% yeah here it's the
proportion who were previously diagnosed
was 42 with the injection drug users so
is 58 didn't know that that they had HIV
69% of the of the MSM didn't know they
had
HIV so much much lower coverage with
testing even though most of them had
been tested in the past it just wasn't
enough so we looked at characteristics
associated with HIV infection and risky
sex for both groups I'll just present it
for HIV infection for ideas today we
controlled for a bunch of potential
co-variants we didn't want to take it
too far because I didn't want it to be a
fishing expedition because we didn't
have that much end to work with and I
didn't want any spurious p-values but
these are the usual suspects I'll just
give you the adjusted odds ratios this
is the odds these are the adjusted odds
ratios for testing HIV positive if you
are a non gay injection drug user in
Russia the women were more likely to
test positive the people who were who
had active employment less people who
were who had a history of incarceration
more and people who resided with their
family we're more likely to test
positive and that is an interesting
thing on a few different levels actually
because one it's an indicator of
socioeconomic status who lives with
their family when they're an adult well
people who don't have the money to live
on their own because no one in their
right mind would do that like choice no
and it also means that you don't get to
shoot up at the kitchen table do you you
know you're not going to do it in in
front of mama and papa
and you know you're Kira it's just not
going to work so it it's associated in
some studies with inject with on a
hygienic injection injection practices
because you're doing it on the sly yeah
so we looked at the homosexually active
men where we included the IBUs in here
because we needed to conserve n by any
means possible and HIV infection was
associated with being older than the age
24 or older having a history of drug
injection and negatively associated with
fuller part-time employment things
changed a little because we had this
funny situation where we had a fair
number of men about we had about 15 guys
who everybody got a global question do
you have sex with men do you have sex
with women or do you have sex with both
and about 15 guys said I only have sex
with women we had others who told us
they had sex with men and women but you
know this number said only women so then
they went on to tell us about the two or
three male sex partners that they'd had
when we asked them who the last people
you had sex with work but for coding
reasons just for skip patterns in the
computer program they didn't get asked
questions about so the last time you
were with this guy you know who you've
given the initials TR or whatever what
did you do with him did you have sex
with a condom did you have sex without a
condom you know is it on the internet
you know what did you do a ton of
invasive questions we would ask and they
didn't they didn't answer those things
because they weren't given the question
so we weren't able to assess their
condom use which was highly annoying so
what I did is I limited this to
well guess what okay I limited this this
actually this 253 is wrong it's actually
down by about 20 no by about 15 but
rather than being an injection drug user
the greatest risk when I was able to
assess what your partners were like like
was that last guy you had sex with a
drug injector having a partner who
injected drugs was the highest risk
factor so what does that tell you well
we go back to the earlier slide where we
saw that the HIV prevalence was so much
greater among drug injectors including
the gay men among them then among gay
men this is a bizarre population where
we might actually see gay men getting
HIV from that from the injection drug
users that's just a postulate at this
point I'm basing that on few
observations but we shall see the
prevalence of risky behavior among these
guys was high about 20 percent of them
had ever participated in sex work trade
traded sex for money or drugs about a
third of them had had sex while high in
the last six months with one partner or
another almost half of them had had any
unprotected sex and then when I limited
it I excluded well it's one thing for
you to have unprotected sex with
somebody you've met that night and it's
another thing for you to have
unprotected sex with your partner five
years and you've both been HIV tested
and I excluded those partnerships where
they knew the partner the status and it
was a main partner 42% of them had had
unprotected sex
that is really risky for HIV and the
proportion was greater with all of these
I think no it was greater for sexual
high but was actually lower for
unprotected anal sex for the injection
drug user
get they have more HIV so was the HIV
coming from and then I broke down the
number of partners in the last six
months with whom the last act of anal
intercourse was unprotected so it's not
just this you know this half of people
have had unprotected sex that's the
problem
you know we had 447 percent had no
partners of this 32 percent had one but
then 20 percent of the people of the
guys in the study had had unprotected
anal sex with two guys or more in the
last six months so this is a hierarchy
of risk here we not just have half the
guys engaging in a little bit of risk we
have 20% of them engaging in a lot of
risk in six months period so the the
only independent association with for
unprotected sex with a male partner was
HIV infection negatively associated the
negative guys were much less likely to
report risky sex five of the HIV
positive participants reported
unprotected sex with the total of six
partners but none of them had been
previously diagnosed and none have been
previously diagnosed so we didn't have a
single guy tell us who knew he had HIV
right we tested him for HIV we found out
whether you had HIV have you ever had a
positive test before oh yeah two years
ago none of those guys had told us that
they had unprotected sex with another
guy and we're thinking wow that's really
low but in Russia the laws against
knowingly exposing someone to your HIV
are severe so we're wondering whether
that could be some reporting bias
however we found when we when we looked
at female partnerships that the greatest
predictor of having unprotected sex with
a female partner was having a history of
drug injection it's the ideas
who are crossing over to the females by
and large but four percent four of them
reported unprotected sex with female
partners also four participants all four
participants for ideas
none of these were were gay men they'd
been previously diagnosed three had been
previously diagnosed with HIV so these
guys knew they had HIV and we're having
unprotected sex with their female
partners the funky thing is of the four
women they exposed all were ID use and
two of those had already told the
participant that they were HIV positive
so maybe these guys are making a
decision about which women to expose
because it's like well she already has
HIV so that's one thing or she's an ID
you maybe the decision is to knowingly
expose an ID you partner more than an on
ID you partner but that's that
speculation that's the question that it
raises so what does this tell us about
HIV among drug injectors in st.
Petersburg a lot of HIV particularly
compared to what they had had a few
years earlier many times what the
prevalence is in Western Europe it's
similar to what we saw in Harlem and the
South Bronx at the height of the HIV
epidemic here or at the height of the
HIV epidemic what we saw among gay men
in San Francisco these guys are getting
clobbered and there are other indicators
of rapid transmission that are kind of
independent from these data for instance
they were all of the same genotype but
that's another talk a nice thing is it
allowed us to estimate the number of
active drug injectors in st. Petersburg
about 80,000 give or take 3,000 was a
piece that Robert Hummer and I just put
out that's a lot if half of those people
have HIV and it's been going up the way
it has it makes you wonder at what point
this will begin to saturate because we
really never saw HIV prevalence
above 50% in the United States so will
it start to slow down we don't know what
does it tell us about homosexually
active men in the city
the first caveat is you know the first
thing I said wouldn't I show you this
slide is we have a small end on our
sampling strategy it's limited the
prevalence of HIV infection is about
three quarters what it is in Western
Europe which means given the size of the
study it's not that different the
prevalence of risk behavior is about the
same about 37 percent of these guys
we're taking know 42 percent of these
guys we're taking serious risk that's
pretty close to what you would see in
Spain a front and with HIV cero
incidence among gay men is about two
percent in Western Europe North America
New Zealand it's a little less in
Australia we we can wonder whether we're
having a similar cereal in Siddhant
there the number of new infections per
hundred years of uninfected person time
here's the funky thing though in the
West current prevalence was preceded by
a much greater prevalence 10-15 years
ago we had a very high HIV prevalence
among gay men in the United States it
went down for a while because those guys
died because it was before the time of
heart if this you know if HIV prevalence
among gay men and Russia has been very
low until recently and we've got these
high rates of unprotected sexual contact
between them it's emerging into a pretty
I don't want to say naive population
because that means you've never been
exposed before so I'm being a good
epidemiologist but what it means is
there could be an awful lot of
susceptible guys to infect so the
incidence could actually wind up being
greater than what it is in Western
Europe
so if the prevalences were until
recently in low in Russia what does this
mean with this rate of contact and the
current rate of prevalence if that's a
new rate of prevalence if that's an
emerging infection we'll have to do more
work to get to that it also tells us
that we have some questions about
bisexuality drug injection and sex work
we didn't have a lot of information on
the bisexual guys the ones who didn't
provide it said they were heterosexual
it's like the t-shirt that was running
around in the 90s the guys wore that
said I'm not gay but my boyfriend is
that's weird like who are these other
partners well we had a great problem
getting data on sex work in this study
the sex work questions were a little
we're a little dodgy so what we're kind
of wondering is whether these guys who
said I have no female partners meanwhile
I'll tell you I had sex with male
partner a and male partner B but I won't
tell you what I did with them we're
wondering whether those were sex
partners are trade sex partners and that
this might indicate a lot of our
homosexually active I do use trading sex
with men for money or drugs and not
getting recorded as that and they could
be a source of infection for both male
and female partners so in order to
address these situations we need better
data on gay men in Russia and we're
doing you know it's a it's a really
changing topography this slide I look at
and I go you know what what's emerging
in Russia is that they have the
opportunities for as for gay nightlife
every bit as lame as we have in the
United States this is Central Station
that's a gay bar in st. Petersburg and I
got to tell you I was there in May and
the thing that people kept impressing on
me is this bar couldn't have been here
three years ago this couldn't have
existed this is totally new that all
these people you see out here dancing
and having
fun this is only thing really did feel
exciting it's it's it's a watershed
there the other thing that they've got
no you see in the lower left is you can
need a partner online you know it's
easier to find sex online that it is
Domino's and they've got that in they've
got Russian language web sites right now
and you can just dial it up have someone
in your bed that afternoon so what that
raises the question of is if zero
prevalence got to seven percent without
gay bars and without gay internet hookup
sites and 37 percent of the guys having
unprotected sex in the last six months
or forty two rather what's it going to
be with the advent of these new methods
of meeting people you know we just
changed the whole structure there's
another thing that we see which is in
the post-soviet era I talked about
earlier female sex work in trafficking
and women increased along with
transmission transmission risk but it
looks like sex work among men might be
transmitting - might be increasing -
this picture in the lower left I took
from gay travel dot are you which is a
website where if you want to go on sex
travel like you can to Thailand you can
go to Russia and you know this charming
guy on the left here I'm sure is what
the other one because of his great
personality you know it's like it's like
the cheesiest picture I've ever seen it
so scary so if that's an emerging thing
that's gonna that's going to affect the
the the transmission as well so how are
we going to study this stuff now raise
those questions later it raises issues
of controlling transmission I'll jump
back to drug users we've got challenges
in both these areas and addressing
transmission among drug users and gay
men
right now in Russia if you're addicted
to heroin you've really got one mode of
getting help which is you know the narc
ologists the addiction specialists there
are going to lock you up and you're
gonna withdraw which is a painful and
dangerous way to get off heroin which is
what the injection drug users use there
there's no drug substitution therapy
it's illegal you can't get methadone
your doctor can prescribe it for you
pharmacies can Sully's syringes they
don't have needle exchange but syringes
are legal the only thing is every store
you go into whether it's the electronics
store you went in to get a new adapt I
wanted a second adaptor for another plug
you know that kind of thing they all
off-duty cops night of moonlighting
right by the door because it's a chaotic
environment people will just walk out
with stuff otherwise so if you're a
heroin addict you really don't want to
walk up to the corner that you know the
counter at their version of Rite Aid and
buy a pack of syringes you could get
beaten up when you leave you know you
could get harassed later on and we know
from another study that fear of police
arrest for carrying equipment like from
a pharmacy with clean syringes is
associated with risky injection in the
Russian context so this this fear
actually affects not just how we do HIV
prevention work by how we do HIV
prevention research
controlling transmission has some
overall challenges to it our work is is
affected by by factors in both of our
countries especially trying to do this
cross-cultural work drug users are
stigmatized you see this is like one of
the few needle exchanges that happened
in Russia was a pretty grim place gay
men are stigmatized and not prioritized
despite huge epidemiological burden in
both countries it's very difficult for
any work with gay men to have legitimate
with legitimacy the alarming picture
that I have here this guy tried to
organize a Russian gape of a gay pride
parade in Moscow in 2009 and that's what
the mayor how the cops do to him that's
a you know so if you just want to waltz
in as a researcher and say I want to do
this important work with this population
in their country as in ours it might not
get met with the best perception another
real challenge to doing this kind of
work from the perspective of Yale or a
u.s. research or even researchers from
the UK or other areas is there's still a
great deal you know our relationship
with Russia is still burdened by decades
of mistrust in the past you know if you
remember that song from the 80s but if
you think it sounds you know what's the
old joke I'm here from the United States
government and I'm here to help
it's like that sounds bad enough if
you're American but can you imagine if
you're Russian weren't you guys didn't
use to have missiles pointed at us you
know it's a funky relationship so those
are all going to be difficulties that
we're going to have to address we know
little about you know we know more about
about injection drug use and HIV in
Russia a great deal more than we used to
most of what we know is bad and we need
to understand where things are going to
peak whether they're going to whether
HIV is going to spill over into other
populations and part of doing that work
is stymied by difficult attitudes around
drug
use the same thing is going to be is
happening with doing work among gay men
that's just in its infancy but both of
these things have a great a great
potential for future spread so I want to
thank the people that I work with here
at Yale on the South cap study the good
folks at the biomedical Institute who we
work with people DL ceará thanks for the
money ni MH we always appreciate it and
the good people at NGOs tell it and if
you can't see it no it doesn't really
show up well this is the jon snow pub
which is a great place to go for a plain
UK and this is robert himer who's the PI
of the study with our colleagues from
stella at a swanky place in st.
petersburg so I could take questions